kann man als jude gefahrlos bahn fahren
mitten in berlin tagsüber die ehrliche
antwort ist nein innerhalb weniger
stunden sind hier in der hauptstadt
nämlich gleich zwei männer angegriffen
worden aus einem einzigen grund weil sie
juden sind
tatort die berliner s bahn ein
33-jähriger mann fährt am
dienstagnachmittag durch charlottenburg
als er plötzlich von einem fahrgast
antisemitisch beleidigt wird das opfer
verbittet sich diese beleidigung doch
die situation eskaliert der täter packte
den mann am arm schiebt ihn weg und dann
dann kommt ein zweiter angreifer hinzu
plötzlich schlagen also zwei männer
gegen den oberkörper und kopf des
33-jährigen sein fahrgast dazwischen
gehen will steigt er attackierte am s
bahnhof wedding aus die angreifer fahren
weiter fast zeitgleich wird aria hiervon
auch in berlin angegriffen und
beschimpft der rabbiner ist gerade auf
dem weg zum arzt telefoniert auf
hebräisch als folgendes passiert
schulte
umgeschrieben was habe weil ich gesagt
ich war das telefon hat sich durfte
wurmte jude ja und danach mein sohn hat
mir gesagt dass er die
geschichte geschrieben
scheiße schmutzige juden
wir waren schockiert
besonders dramatisch all das muss sein
13 jähriger sohn levi mit ansehen
auch meine frau viele mal gesagt mir und
sonne einmal gesagt sie sollen keeper
mit gibt mit grippe gehen ein tag zwei
angriffe polizei ermittelt in beiden
fällen doch die frage bleibt wie sicher
können jüdische menschen in deutschland
leben
mehr gehen direkt dorthin wo sich das
ganze abgespielt hat unser reporter
handels radig dort für uns vor ort alles
was weißt du über diese tat was genau
ist passiert
genau wir haben's ja der markt schon
grob gehört das ist also der stand der
die polizei heute immer noch
veröffentlicht da ist in der nacht also
keinen verhandlungserfolg leider zu
verzeichnen gewesen gestern kurz vor 15
uhr ist ein 33-jähriger mann hier in
berlin am s bahnhof jungfernstieg in die
s-bahn gestiegen wurde dort
antisemitisch beleidigt hat sich diese
beleidigung verwehrt wurde dann von zwei
männern geschlagen gegen den oberkörper
geboxt und gegen den kopf zum glück ist
ein anderer ein weiterer fahrgast
dazwischengegangen und der 33-jährige
konnte hier am s bahnhof wedding man
sieht ihn hinterher hinter mir die bahn
verlassen und die beiden
judenfeindlichen täter sind mit der bahn
geflohen sie sind immer noch auf der
flucht der staatsschutz ermittelt wegen
volksverhetzung wegen beleidigung und
körperverletzung
und ja es ist der zweite vorfall an
einem tag das ist entsetzlich das ist
zwei zu viel es ist schlimm für für
berlin ich habe mit einem jüdischen
freund gesprochen der seit jahren hier
in berlin lebt mit seiner familie der
aber sagt trotzdem dennoch trotz dieser
vorfälle fühle ich mich sicher in berlin
und trotzdem obwohl ich mich sicher
fühle
beherzige ich einige vorsichtsmaßnahmen
und das ist zum beispiel dass wenn sie
am schabbat aus der synagoge kommen er
mit seiner familie dass er und sein sohn
sofort die kippa abnehmens schon auf dem
bürgersteig und in die tasche stecken
damit sie eben auf der straße nicht als
jugend erkannt werden er sagt aber auch
dass er dieses gleiche verhalten in
teilen israels an den tag legt die eben
arabisch dominiert sind und hier im
wedding ist eben eine relativ hohe
migrations dichte und auch in der s bahn
die zwischen charlottenburg und wedding
offensichtlich auch wir wissen aber
natürlich nicht ob die täter aus dem
rechtsradikalen milieu kommen oder
migrationshintergrund hatten das muss
man ganz klar sagen dennoch ist es so
dass dieser freund von mir mit dem
gestern lange nach diesen vorfällen
telefoniert aber auch gesagt hat er
fühlt sich sicher sein sohn bekommt zb
polizeischutz der geht auf die
israelische schule auf die jüdische
schule und wenn dies im sportunterricht
laufen auf der straße haben die eine
polizei eskorte sagt das ist komisch
aber er fühlt sich sicher und er weiß
dass sein sohn gut und sicher am
sportplatz ankommt und dennoch sagt er
hat deutschland ein großes defizit in
der politischen bildung bei den
schulkindern aber eben auch bei
migranten bei flüchtlingen die zu uns
kommen als gäste oder als schutz
suchende in unser land kommt und da sagt
er da ist die haupt koks dass diese
menschen eben nicht wirklich politisch
gebildet werden und den erklärt wird
dass auch eine kritik vielleicht sogar
eine berechtigte kritik vor ihrer
meinung nach an der politik israels eben
nichts mit jüdischen mitbürger hier auf
der straße zu tun dass die gefälligst
wie jeder andere hier in berlin in
frieden leben dürfen sagt dir dein
jüdischer freund sagt bild-reporter
hannes grafik und auch wir sprechen mit
einem jüdischen freund mit sigmund
königsberg dem antisemitismus
beauftragten der jüdischen gemeinde in
berlin größe sehr königsberg einen
schönen guten morgen zwei solche
antisemitische solche judenfeindliche
angriffe in oder vor der s-bahn und
u-bahn hier berlin innerhalb weniger
stunden
uns verschlägt es die sprache wie geht
es ihnen damit
altersgerecht ich weiß von den kollegen
der recherchen informationsstelle
antisemitismus dass wir gegen tat drei
antisemitischer vorfälle haben mich
alles nicht so schlimm und so gravierend
wie ich diese beiden aber antisemitismus
gehört zum alltag das ist für uns nichts
neues das ist für uns alltag und was ihr
reporter geschildert hat was ein bücher
freigestellt hat ja wir versuchen
möglichst unauffällig zu sein benehmen
die kippa ab wenn wir uns in der
öffentlichkeit
bewegen es wohl besser als kind da war
ich sechs jahre alt von meiner mutter
sozusagen mit gegeben
wir versuchen hier nicht ausgefahren und
auch das kind auf der jüdischen schule
ja da ist es sicher dass polizeischutz
ja wenn die kinder haupt am ende
ziemlich es eine sporthalle kind von der
freizeit geleitet aber das ist doch ein
zeichen dass eben kinder vorwiegend
eigentlich am jüdischen schulen sicher
sind und sie die erfahrung auf die
erfahrung machen müssen dass an
staatlichen schulen dieser schritt nicht
gegeben das ist das traurige dabei ist
nur an jüdische schule neben ein
geschützter raum gegeben
es ist sehr traurig das ist noch mehr
als das es ist beschämend
es ist beschämend dass solche attacken
passieren dass kinder von der polizei
begleitet werden das ist für sie wie sie
schildern alltag geworden ist dass wenn
die kita in der tasche steckt und sie
nicht tragen kann was muss passieren was
sagen sie auch der politik das ist doch
ein riesengroßes versagen
jeden einzelnen weil die täter können
deswegen oft so handeln bei selten
interveniert wird hier im falken der
s-bahn ist jemand da durchgegangen und
der mann hat die chance sich hier dieser
bedrohlichen situation zu entziehen aber
oft passiert gar nichts das ist das
allererste
und
politik ist das eine aber
haben die rechtsprechung ist noch ein
anderes thema es ist
wirklich beschämend dass antisemitische
hast täter wie bei dieser folgt lehrer
in anführungszeichen als freie läuft das
gericht verlassen können dass hier sind
das sind nur teile die von gerichten
getroffen werden die und treffen wo man
das gefühl hat hier
antisemitismus wird von der justiz nicht
so geartet wie die rechtslage bisher
gema das ist hier schon das ist im punkt
danke für ihre klaren worte herr
königsberg siegmund königsberg der
antisemitismus beauftragte der jüdischen
gemeinde in berlin der herr uns im
grunde allen sagt wir alle müssen zur
antisemitismus beauftragten werden in
dieser zeit später ist es jetzt danke
danke schön